michel david michels urgent et qu'il
sort du four bonsoir bonsoir je le
disais avant la pause on se serait
attendu un débat un peu plus élevé la
journée même de la commémoration de la
mort de joyce et chaque one ou salon
bleu
le principe de joe istres pour que les
gens comprennent bien l'extrait qu'on va
qu'on veut entendre c'est le chef de
manawan qu'il dit il faut reconnaître un
certain nombre de choses qui parmi
beaucoup beaucoup de mots il ya
effectivement la systémique là mais
c'est pas les sanglés plutôt une main
tendue bien pour nos deux nations
sentant mieux en deux mois on écoute un
échange qui a dérapé à l'assemblée
nationale
pour ça il faut collectivement franchir
une étape celui de reconnaître le
principe de tourisme je demande au
premier ministre qu'on puisse poser ces
gestes aujourd'hui sur le président je
suis d'accord que le principe de joyce
là où j'ai un problème c'est quand on
voit nue vidéo du député de jacques
cartier qui fait un amalgame en joyce et
chaque coin juge je suis outré que le
premier ministre wen choisissent cette
question là cette question là sur le
principe de jobs sur la réalité que
vivent les peuples autochtones au québec
sur la réalité que vivent ses sept
enfants l'eau pour s'en prendre à la
conduite d'un député qui n'a absolument
rien à se reprocher surprise dans 15 ans
tal les petits de robert baldwin quand
j'entends l'a dit petit saint laurent
monsieur le président même pas laisser
le premier ministre répond à ces
questions il ya un enjeu et c'est
peut-être seul débat monsieur le
président
alors tour de table michel david qu'est
ce que vous en avez pensé bah j'ai vu
que le policier qui a repris ses droits
même pas été longs à une journée ou
après ça on avait dû avoir un peu plus
d'élévation
maintenant c'est le même débat qui
revient sous une autre forme sur leurs
assauts systémique qu'on a depuis qui
date d'avant de la mort de madame et
chaque one et qu'est ce que vous voulez
le premier ministre s'est un peu
peinturer dans le coin depuis le début
en dix ans il y en a pas de rester
systémique je pense j'ai trop pensé que
s'il y avait tellement accusé philippe
couillard de vouloir culpabiliser les
québécois accueillis et pris avec un
discours qu'il ne peut pas changer
maintenant j'ai pas vu la vidéo de
cette vieille vidéo ou kelly
dit il faut faire attention il dit
le gouvernement qui a tendance à trop
s'employer la clause discriminatoire
donc à m mais c'est une vieille vidéo du
mois de juin associer disons le ce qui
est arrivé à madame mais chaque fois
dans les bras ou 96 là en partant il ya
quelque chose qui marche pas
mais j'ai toujours l'impression aussi
que dans le cas des autochtones
peut-être que monsieur lebon est très
certainement beaucoup de québécois
seraient prêts à dire il ya
effectivement durée systémique mais à
partir du moment où on dit oui les
autochtones mais inévitablement il
faudrait considérer que les autres
communautés au affaibli communautés
cultuelles qui a pas que les premières
nations ont peut pas on peut poser base
autres oui c'est vrai mais les autres
c'est pas vrai alors monsieur legault
hockey et qu'on sait qu'à avec son déni
chasser auger mais oui on peut être
totalement contre ce qu'a dit qu'elle
est dans une vidéo de mois de juin
est-ce que c'était le moment d'en parler
c'est un peu sommes à ma question non ce
n'est pas le moment d'en parler s'était
pas sur le gaudy a fait un amalgame chez
de sapri amalgame
c'était pas la journée pour faire ça
mais c'est ainsi monsieur beau sur ces
questions-là tire sur tout ce qui bouge
depuis qu'il a décidé qu'ils étaient de
chef de la nation il tire littéralement
sur tout ce qui bouge on voit ça va lui
passer mes journées comme aujourd'hui ce
n'est pas assez simple je pense que
les mots de mon collègue david sont les
bons ils ces peintures et dans un
courrier dans cette affaire là la
plupart des québécois ça capable de
reconnaître que on a un problème de
racisme envers des autochtones au québec
mais pas de système magique l'a6
l'espace ans mais il ya un problème
la question jones et chaque année il y
en a eu d'autres qui se serait
m'adresser pas inutile de nommer les
choses et christian vous est il faut le
dire depuis le début vous dit ce débat
là on va devenir fou n'empêche
aujourd'hui que tous vos amis comment
vous avez reçu ça j'ai trouvé ce triste
en fait que l'attention soit diversier
de l'essentiel l'essentiel c'est écrit
que la mort de madame et chaque année
pas du tout passé inaperçu des fois il y
aurait eu mille marque change pas
grand-chose cette mort là il noté on l'a
commandement après la pollution c'est
quand ça devient politique on se bat pas
brider racisme je colle accord avec mes
deux collègues monsieur legault hip hop
peinture est dans le coin je pense
qu'ils se posent et il a raison de se
poser fermement à ce concept locke est
essentiellement liée au
multiculturalisme canadien lorsqu'il
autres toxiques avec culture politique
américaine et même à la culture rock
c'est pas un concept de toit et on peut
être propre et dénoncer totalement le
racisme à l'égard des objectifs nos
points c'est vrai qu'ils avaient 35 ans
spécifique michel avait deux raisons si
c'était juste les autochtones c'est vrai
que la loi sur les indiens puis en haut
du ressuscité vite mais d'actu mais la
met dans le tordeur s'il fallait que le
gouvernement se contente il fait bien de
prononcer des gens on voit du repao déjà
on voit du racisme partout imaginez si
québec s'embarquant plus dans une
voiture essence formule du racisme
estimé c'est un concept censé mois
politiques ont du mal à faire embarquer
mais là christian il n'avait pas besoin
de reconnaître tout bataclan duras
insisté mais il pouvait dire comme il le
dit d'ailleurs je suis d'accord avec la
déclaration de john la main tendue et
pas assez bizarre oui on est très est-ce
qu'à chaque fois le meilleur parce que
celui qui était à l'offensive
aujourd'hui tapas libéraux là-dessus
lost est à l'huile je n'ai pas tout
écouter mais reste correct et la
déclaration de jouissance à comprendre
oui ça fait partie du portrait et
monsieur monsieur legault ne peut pas
dire tout accord avec ça je trouve
l'opposition etc les messieurs legault
n'acceptera jamais le racisme systémique
oublions ça je pense que la majorité des
équipes quoi ne sont pas d'accord avec
cette reconnaissance là parce qu'il
semble que salim est trop dans une
situation ils ont l'air et c'est dommage
je le rappelle parce qu'il est
essentielle se pose arrêtons de faire
cette cession de l'essentiel c'est que
du racisme et québec comme ailleurs il
faut le dénoncer c'est ça l'essentiel
moi je ne parlais pas de rester si ces
mecs nus tt cet échange l'assemblée
nationale
n'est ce pas nous qui en avons parlé la
scène locale c'est
donc le nom mais je parlais de 2,6
systémique je parle pas de nous vendre
assister mais pour ou qu'on
s'est emparé de la déclaration de joyce
aujourd'hui oui et michel sait pas
comment cette politique là je ne sais
pas il ya déjà il ya des gens qui sont
pas des farfelus qui sont pas des oies
qui sont utilisés de façon très sérieuse
la situation des autochtones au québec
le juge vient par exemple apprendre de
la com sur dix qui parle lui de la
systémique
mais je dirais un moment donné il ya une
réalité envers des autochtones au québec
qui est difficile les autres
c'est ça aujourd'hui la crise y est
nombreux à remettre la médaille il peut
retourner dans une panique pour le sec a
prévenu ce qu'avec notre systémique
points parce que si je le fais pour les
objecteurs michel david de 10 s'il le
fait plus de personnes va être content
de le faire pour tous les os michel
davet conclusion les oui mais il devait
justement f1 pour tous les autres mois
j'avais pas comprendre comment ça se
fait que le québec non seulement en
amérique du nord m'a peu près partout en
accident serait la seule société qui
sinon monsieur ça non michel christian
ce que je peux terminer y'a pas de honte
à avouer qu'on a un problème de cet
ordre là est le meilleur moyen de
commencer à le régler celle de leur
reconnaître les réduire ça à
racisme individuel c'est nier le
problème là quand on a un problème avec
la justice la police le logement
l'emploi
le système de santé ça commence à être
pas mal systémique soleure ok on se fait
une dynamique nord américaines tuent de
la victoire américaine michelle en
europe le racisme
ont pu très bien que les gens qui
comptent et sion s'est pas dit si nos
salles on le sait bien que c'est pas
juste individuel mon est conscient du
fait que c'est un concept très marqués
politiquement à
contenir des dérives très bien mais ça
existe il faut pas dire
c'est un concept politique ces immigrés
sur mon va un autre débat un autre débat
je veux entendre la ceni les
manufacturiers qui lance un millième
cris d'allah mazza il manque de monde et
un veulent ça c'est pas nouveau le parti
libéral ou si vous allez l'entendre en
échange veulent monter les seuils
d'immigration pour amener des
travailleurs davantage au québec voici
ce que ça a donné le premier ministre
s'est levé combien de fois pour parler
de l'importance de produire au québec ce
sont ces manufacturiers québécois qui
sont en train de s'adresser à lui en lui
disant qu'ils ont besoin de son soutien
les manufacturiers parti libéral volonté
non immigrants nous on pense que le
québec a atteint sa capacité
d'intégration
alors michel si je commence avec vos
capacités d'intégration atteintes
qui a décidé sa clé qui va hâter sa
capacité d'intégration ce qui a eu une
étude est ce que le ministère a fait une
fugue là dessus est ce qu'il ya eu une
commission d enquête non c'est ce que
monsieur le groupe si ça ça s'appelle
une opinion c'est l'opinion de chez le
gros c'est vrai il ya beaucoup d'autres
opinions y compris celle des
manufacturiers qui ont qui aurait qui
sont intervenus aujourd'hui mais cale
prenez mini cela nous de façon
péremptoire le québec a atteint sa
capacité d'absorption parce que moi je
ne sais et moi je lui dis si
c'est pas comme ça que ça se passe dans
ma loge et démocratie christian
rappelons quand même que le québec par
rapport à sa population est une des
sociétés au monde qui reçoit le plus
d'immigrés je pense que je suis est
ravie qui nous dépasse le problème et on
marche beaucoup de migrants les pointes
contient des salles on ne ressent plus
la france suspicieuse ni par rapport à
la population choisit le problème est
très réelle moi je suis à
baie-saint-paul quelques jours et je
m'attends devrait pas aller déjeuner
parce que les restaurants ferment pas
demandeur c'est très très concret le
problème est réel en même temps moi la
capacité d'intégration du québec je suis
estime passant entre sur le plan est
quand même et réalise historiquement le
québec francophone on ne soit essayer d
assimiler par l'immigration dont j'ai
pas de solution au problème si je sais
que c'est pas juste de la main d'oeuvre
spécialisée en tout cas des symboles ce
n'est pas de la main d'oeuvre
spécialisée c'était des restaurants qui
étaient systématiquement la solution je
le fais pas michel navy moi je suis
assez d'accord avec monsieur legault et
je pense qu'on peut pour réduire
l'immigration un problème économique il
ya ça fait partie d'un ensemble et au
moment où le gouvernement on débat à
l'assemblée nationale enfin commission
parlementaire avec seulement 2 d'un
projet de loi qui qui essaient de
commandes et de freiner l'anglicisation
alors il ya plusieurs aspects à
l'immigration je suis d'accord qu'il ya
un problème de pénurie de main d'oeuvre
c'est évident mais je pense pas que
aussi les seuils de d'immigration soit
une solution absolument pas et il ya je
pense monsieur fils benoît raison il ya
une partie du problème qui peut être
réglé par la requalification de la main
d'oeuvre mais réduire sa un problème
d'immigration je trouve que c'est tout à
fait passer à côté de l'ensemble des
problématiques
de du français au québec très bien autre
sujet hélas avoir lancé les débats sur
les champs de compétence monsieur
trudeau persiste et signe si vous
pensiez qu'il allait dire bombay dans le
fond il y aura pas trop de conditions
j'augmente les transferts
inconditionnel aux provinces voici ce
qu'il a plutôt dit ce que vous comptez
gouverné pendant quatre ans sans
déclencher des élections j'espère
certainement que les canadiens ont donné
des indications qui voulait un
gouvernement qui travaillaient sur les
grands enjeux en partenariat avec
d'autres et c'est exactement ce que nous
allons faire
vous aurez compris que c'est impossible
assène l'homme c'est intéressant aussi
c'est à dessein et j'ai compris le
message je veux gouverner 4 1 fin de la
parenthèse mais l'autre est ce qu'on la
wii je crois un autre c'est sur les
conditions du transfert ensemble non on
va être là pour augmenter les transferts
en santé à vers les provinces et gèrent
de m'asseoir pour en discuter mais comme
j'ai aussi dit pendant les élections
nous nous attendons à un niveau de
transparence et de redevabilité ce sera
pas sans conditions mais on va discuter
avec les provinces sur comment nous
allons pouvoir s'assurer que les gens à
travers le pays reçoivent les services
nécessaires avec les investissements à
des dollars des contribuables
ça ne se ça ne sera pas sans conditions
mais celle de vie c'est absolument pas
surprenants sur leurs goûts monsieur
monsieur trudeau et
est conséquent avec lui-même il ya
toujours dit ça maintenant on aurait pu
espérer que bon après l'élection
monsieur trudeau est encore minoritaire
il y avait pu on aurait pu espérer mais
honnêtement je m'attendais pas à ça mais
je dois quand même revenir juste un peu
sur la première partie de la clique
qu'on a passé
il me suit trudeau a dit oui je l'espère
mais à une autre question un moment
donné il y est dit si l'opposition
demeurant vers ce poste le gouvernement
ait pas renverser
un gouvernement peut toujours un moment
donné m un espèce de pilule empoisonnée
là que ce soit dans un budget dans un
projet de loi pour faire en sorte que
l'opposition puisse pas l'accepter et le
renverser alors la promesse de monsieur
trouve a fait la promesse le voeu de
monsieur trudeau
disons il pourrait facilement lui même
faire en sorte qu'ils ne se réalisent
pas ouais mais on sait qu'il ya quand
même eu un message de de passer par
l'électorat canadien assez clair mais je
sais auger sur
les marges le choisissez mais sur les
conditions de sol sous les comptes sur
le site un vieux discours dépassé qui
lui tenait sont sa raison d'être si
ç'avait été vrai sur le fait que
certaines provinces dépensez pas tout
l'argent qu'ils recevaient du fédéral en
soins de santé ne se fait d'elle
tellement baissé sa contribution vous
pouvez absolument certain que chaque
scène que le groupe que le fédéral
envoie
pour la santé est dépensé en santé les
provinces qui n'est au secours là dessus
de façon unanime alors ce que monsieur
trudeau dit lassé du vieux discours ça
n'a plus sa raison d'être
emmené le chèque seront consolidées que
c'est ton concept book mais ça c'est
bien qu'avec mes jeux d'il ya plus de il
ya plus personne au canada qui pense que
quelque part des méchantes province se
servent de cet argent
pour baisser les impôts souvenez-vous le
fisc
allemand
christian est la question c'est est ce
que les provinces ont le gros bout du
bâton ou sais pas monsieur trudeau
maintenant qu'un euro moody's bonne voie
je pense que monsieur trudeau quand même
davantage de la boxe clairement qui
poserait des conditions j'aimerais
croire ce que vient de dire mais aussi
roger mais j'en suis moins sûr il est
quand même arrivé quelque chose dans la
crise center au québec c'est que le
québec failli dans la gestion des sièges
cod on a demandé
l'aide de l'armée et j'écoutais la
conférence de presse de monsieur testé
doigt parce qu'on est
j'écoutais la conférence de presse de
monsieur truc c'est 60 parce qu avait
rien de nouveau et puis j'en avais suis
dit est ce qu'il ya un élément nouveau
que vous allez faire dans votre poche
l'hadopi ou pas été capable d'en donner
un on avait neuf autres qui s'était rien
passé sauf moi je trouve l'élément
nouveau c'est qu'ils annoncent une
offensive fédéral dans les champs de
compétence provisions peut-être que je
dramatise mais il reste qu'il n'en a
parlé durant la campagne il persiste et
cp en fait pour venir peut-être de deux
secondes sur un script des élections aux
postes
entre vous et moi c'est facile de dire
quelque chose d'une semaine après mes
promesses d'ivrogne ils nous disent oh
mais on n'en sait rien en six mois dans
un havre de dans le contexte peut te
marres chargé tout est possible je
trouvais ça après midi avec monsieur
triaud c'est dépassé ils sont adeptes de
la langue de bois mais il ya battu ses
propres records franchement acquérir
parler il parlait parlait d'un autre
chose mais il y avait rien de nouveau
j'ai un sujet je vous avais difficile
mais je vais laisser michel david en
parle vous avez fait de chroniques
michel david j'ai relu il était très tôt
ce matin le titre deux fois jusqu'à
michel avait dit que le goût est pire
que trudeau vice assas poker mais vous
parlez du de la clarté justement comme
ceux trudeau et a déchiré sa promesse de
réformer le mode de scrutin mais il l'a
fait comme clairement qu'un patient il
passe à autre chose lui et la gauche
fait ça mais il dit pas ouais monsieur
monsieur trudeau a été clair et cynique
parce qu'il le dit écoutez le système a
produit un gouvernement que les gens
aiment donc on regarde son gouvernement
à lui monsieur legault lui
d'abord s'est engagé beaucoup plus
fermement que monsieur trudeau a changé
le mode de scrutin et il fait encore
semblant qu'ils veulent qu'il dit encore
qu'il veut le faire mais concrètement
ils s'organisent pour que ça ne se fasse
pas le projet de loi qu'on soit pour ou
contre c'est plus la l'éthique politique
de monsieur legault que je discute ici
monsieur legault
honnêtement là il fait en sorte que son
projet de loi ne sera pas adopté avant
la fin de leur efficience de
référendum il est déjà acquis qui pourra
pas y en avoir un
à l'élection parce que le directeur
général des élections [ __ ] mais là il
y aura peut-être mais pas de projet de
loi avant l'élection et apprécié ce
projet de loi là va mourir et qu'est ce
qu'il en adviendra sur la suite qui s'en
va l'applaudir vous êtes content vous la
réforme du mode mais
effectivement insulté un peu de clarté
non mais je trouve ça très intéressant
en fait l'article de michel que je
sentais beaucoup de frustration il parle
des dignes de choquant de running man
d'hypocrisie donc mais heureusement il
semble pas croire que la réforme du mode
de scrutin doit avoir lieu ce qui me
ravit pas prévu ça je rêve je
rappellerai mon ami michel qu'on est
pauvre en morale on est en politique
c'est une promesse électorale mala
visible sur un logo reviennent à tuer
tant mieux
non mais il revient pas il fait sans
bain de l'avenir tout en guettant des
messieurs merci au revoir à la prochaine
fallu
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici r d